[Música]
gracias por seguir con nosotros hoy en 5
minutos con nos acompaña el doctor
alejandro rojas académico de la
universidad austral de chile miembro de
la coalición coreana contra enfermedades
infecciosas cocyt gracias por estar con
nosotros doctor en sí le han estado
estudiando como el sistema inmune de los
camélidos específicamente de alpacas
puede ser beneficioso en el combate
contra el coronavirus que es lo que han
encontrado durante esta investigación
hola buenos días mira el sistema inmune
de las alpacas y en particular sus dan
sus anticuerpos son muchísimo más
simples que los anticuerpos de cualquier
otro mamífero por lo tanto hemos sido
capaces de inmunizar la causa de generar
anticuerpos y posteriormente a partir de
una pequeña muestra de sangre logramos
aislar esto estos anticuerpos y
transportarlos dentro de microorganismos
como bacterias en los últimos meses
hemos desarrollado un anticuerpo muy
poderoso capaz de unirse a la superficie
del virus pero más aún es capaz de
neutralizar los según es justamente en
la llave que cuenta este virus para
poder entrar a las células por lo tanto
con este anticuerpo hoy día estamos en
colaboración con muchos países
intentando desarrollar herramientas para
poder generar un nebulizador queremos
administrarlo a través de la vía aérea a
través de un nebulizador para poder
bloquear la replicación del virus en la
vía aérea y así también para la
replicación del virus en la parte
profunda de proponerlo al biólogo y
hacer que las personas no se compliquen
que no terminen sometidos a una terapia
o eventualmente que se desencadene en la
muerte del paciente ahora de qué manera
podría ayudar ese anticuerpo al cuerpo
humano
y mayoría del virus tiene un problema el
virus nuevos nuevos entonces no tenemos
anticuerpos cuando nos enfrentamos a la
infección pero sin embargo si nosotros
pudiésemos entregarle el virus el
anticuerpo o una persona de alguna forma
estamos pidiéndole prestado al sistema
inmune de una alpaca para poder
protegernos parecido lo que pasó con el
presidente de trump cuando se le agregó
un anticuerpo de ratón con un anticuerpo
humano en realidad esto es exactamente
lo mismo pero con un anticuerpo
muchísimo es más chiquitito muchísimo
más barato y que se puede producir de
forma ilimitada le pregunto doctor si
han hecho pruebas en personas
todo hasta el momento hemos hecho
pruebas con el virus extraído de
personas pero no hemos hecho las pruebas
en personas estamos hemos recibido ahora
el apoyo del parlamento en chile se le
solicitó el presidente de la republica
financiar los estudios preclínicos en
modelos animales y finalmente también el
estudio en persona esperamos que el
presidente acoja la solicitud de
parlamento ahora cuál sería el efecto de
este anticuerpo en una persona ya
contagiada con kobe 19
imagínate se han probado anticuerpos de
camélidos dos alpacas con el virus
sincicial que un vino respiratorio que
afecta niños en este caso después de la
primera dosis la cantidad de virus
bajaba de forma drástica drástica y más
de 7.000 veces por lo tanto lo que lo
que esperamos es que luego de de aplicar
esto a través de un nebulizador el virus
se bloquear la vía aérea y se deje de
replicar por lo tanto la persona no se
agrave
ahora le pregunto si tienen todos los
recursos para esta investigación que
están desarrollando que les que les
podría faltar
bueno mira hemos llegado al punto donde
hay que realizar el ensayo clínico y eso
es caro nosotros estamos pidiendo al
gobierno sea que a 4 millones de dólares
que nos alcanzaría para poder llevar
esto a los pacientes eso es lo que nos
falta hoy día
doctor también le quiero preguntar
entonces para cuando ustedes tienen
pensado terminar esta investigación para
llevarla a cabo a lo mejor no sea de las
primeras pruebas en humanos para cuando
tienen estipulados para cuando tenían
estipulados que sea esto
mirad va a depender un poco de cuando
nosotros encontremos finalmente
financiamiento sin embargo esperamos que
en el comienzo de un estudio clínico no
demore más allá de ocho meses o sea
significa que empezar a probar en
personas que sea seguro alrededor de
ocho meses una vez completado todos los
procesos de acuerdo a la legislación de
la agencia sanitarios correspondientes
que tan seguro sería esta prueba
hasta el momento nunca ha habido un
efecto colateral de un anticuerpo de
camerún como tal ha habido un efecto muy
muy menor por lo tanto esperamos que sea
un efecto seguro o sea que una
aplicación se aseguren las personas
doctor muchísimas gracias por su tiempo
por estar aquí con nosotros en france 24
feliz día ustedes continuarán con
nosotros hay mucho más valor acá
[Música]